[Musica]
come nasce il senso di responsabilità
quali sono i processi che ci consentono
di sentirci responsabili delle nostre
azioni e degli effetti che questi
producono nell'ambiente esterno
possiamo forse essere ritenuti meno
responsabili quando agiamo per obbedire
ad una decisione presa ad esempio dal
nostro superiore come nel tragico caso
della funivia di stresa e viceversa il
leader di un movimento può essere
considerato responsabile di azioni non
intraprese direttamente da lui ma dai
membri del suo gruppo come nel caso
dell'assalto al parlamento americano lo
scorso gennaio e cosa succede nel nostro
cervello in queste specifiche
circostanze
questi sono alcuni degli interrogativi
che guidano la mia attività di ricerca
come neuroscienziata cognitiva un lavoro
in cui cerco di mettere in relazione il
nostro comportamento con il
funzionamento del nostro cervello
tramite esperimenti scientifici e
avanzate tecniche strumentali come la
risonanza magnetica funzionale
con le mie ricerche
cerco di studiare i processi cognitivi e
cerebrali alla base del senso di
responsabilità che rappresenta una con
una componente fondamentale della
consapevolezza di sé caratteristica
della natura umana e senza la quale non
potrà interagire efficacemente con le
altre persone più in generale quella
società moderna in cui viviamo ma prima
di entrare nel dettaglio delle mie
ricerche facciamo un passo indietro è
davvero possibile misurare una
sensazione così soggettiva come il senso
di responsabilità in un contesto così
artificiale come quello di un
esperimento scientifico
la risposta è sì ed esistono addirittura
diverse modalità di misurazione del
senso di responsabilità
la prima è la più immediata la più
intuitiva e consiste nel coinvolgere i
partecipanti di un esperimento in una
serie di azioni che possono portare ad
effetti più o meno coerenti con tali
azioni e successivamente chiedere ai
nostri soggetti quanto si sono sentiti
responsabili di quegli specie perfetti
ad esempio se una scala che può variare
tra 0 e 100
tuttavia questa modalità di misurazione
del senso di responsabilità non mi ma la
nostra quotidiana esperienza di
responsabilità che spesso è automatica
implicita e influisce sullo sfondo del
nostro comportamento
per questo motivo gli psicologi
sperimentali negli ultimi vent'anni
hanno individuato una serie di errori
percettivi in cui incorre il nostro
cervello che hanno la funzione di
etichettare quali effetti sono stati
prodotti dalle nostre azioni per
distinguerli da ciò che invece viene
prodotto dalle azioni altrui e in
generale dall'esterno ad esempio il
nostro cervello tende a percepire come
attenuato dal punto di vista sensoriale
ciò che viene prodotto direttamente da
noi c'è un esempio molto chiaro di tutto
ciò è del fenomeno del solletico
se voi ci pensa pensate è praticamente
impossibile farci solletico da soli e
questo succede perché il nostro cervello
nel momento in cui mettiamo in atto
un'azione
automaticamente ne simula né predice le
probabili conseguenze e nel momento in
cui si verifica una corrispondenza tra
queste previsioni e le conseguenze
effettive percepite il cervello
automaticamente etichetterà come questo
come tratte da noi queste conseguenze e
le attenuerà dal punto di vista
sensoriale quindi nel caso del solletico
il nostro cervello percepire alla
sensazione tattile come prodotta dalla
nostra azione la ridurla nel ridurre
l'intensità dal punto di vista
sensoriale e questo determinerà
l'assenza della sensazione di solletico
c'è un'altra strategia che il cervello
usate a etichettare gli effetti delle
nostre azioni e questa volta è legata
più alla dimensione temporale la nostra
mente infatti tende a legare insieme dal
punto di vista temporale le azioni le
nostre azioni con gli effetti che queste
producono nell'ambiente esterno quindi
ad esempio se noi suoniamo un
interruttore schiacciamo un interruttore
per suonare un campanello
percepiremo l'intervallo di tempo che
passa tra la pressione dell'interruttore
il suono del campanello come complesso
come ridotto dal punto di vista
temporale più forte questa compressione
temporale più forte il nostro senso di
responsabilità verso quello specifico
effetto e quindi questa misura può
essere utilizzata indirettamente come
indice del senso di responsabilità
in un mio recente studio ci siamo
serviti proprio di questa misura del
senso di responsabilità per indagare che
cosa succede nel nostro cervello quando
ci sentiamo responsabili di un azione e
dei suoi effetti e per fare ciò abbiamo
ideato un esperimento che partisse da
una situazione
semplicissima replicabile in laboratorio
kimi masse un'azione quotidiana che
ognuno di noi svolge abitualmente
l'accensione di una lampadina quindi in
alcuni casi i nostri soggetti premevano
un interruttore per accendere una
lampadina mentre in altri casi
erano istruiti a rimanere fermi perché è
uno sperimentatore che rappresenta e con
loro il laboratorio premeva il loro dito
sull'interruttore e questa pressione
portava comunque l'accensione della
lampadina quindi l'idea era quella di
creare una condizione diretta
caratterizzata da un'azione volontaria
seguita da una conseguenza di cui
soggetti si sentissero direttamente
responsabili da confrontare con una
condizione invece in diretta
caratterizzata da nazione e passiva
involontaria ma seguita dalla medesima
conseguenza abbiamo poi chiesto ai
nostri soggetti di stimare secondo loro
quanto tempo era passato tra la
pressione dell'interruttore e
l'accensione della lampadina per
misurare quel fenomeno di compressione
temporale che abbiamo visto essere un
indice del senso di responsabilità
i nostri risultati a livello di
comportamento hanno
evidenziato effettivamente come ci
aspettavamo ti dai soggetti si sentivano
più responsabili delle azioni ed effetti
del nostro esperimento quando erano loro
ad agire volontariamente piuttosto che
quando invece agivano passivamente
quindi ci siamo chiesti che cosa
succedesse nel loro cervello in queste
specifiche condizioni
e per fare ciò abbiamo utilizzato una
tecnica che si chiama risonanza
magnetica funzionale ti consente non
solo di fare una fotografia del cervello
ma anche di vedere quali aria cerebrali
sono attive durante lo svolgimento di
uno specifico comportamento ci consente
quindi di andare a guardare all'interno
del cervello mentre il cervello al
lavoro
grazie a questa tecnica abbiamo visto
che più i nostri soggetti si sentivano
responsabili delle azioni ed effetti che
abbiamo testato nel nostro esperimento
maggiore era l'attività in una serie di
aree cerebrali a livello delle aree
premotorie che si trovano qui davanti le
aree parietali qui dietro e le aree
cerebellari quindi in basso quindi
possiamo dire che sì esiste un network
di aree cerebrali
la cui attività da vita al senso di
responsabilità ed è interessante notare
come queste regioni siano imparentate
con quelle dell'intenzionalità motoria
cioè quelle regioni cerebrali che ci
consentono di agire secondo la nostra
volontà piuttosto che automaticamente
ma non ci siamo fermati a questo abbiamo
deciso anche di utilizzare una tecnica
che si chiama stimolazione magnetica
transcranica
che permette di interferire in modo
ovviamente temporaneo e non invasivo con
l'attività del cervello e abbiamo visto
che alterare la l'attività delle regioni
cerebrali che vi ho appena presentato
portava anche a un'alterazione del senso
di responsabilità nel senso che i nostri
soggetti erano portati a sentirsi
responsabili di azione del 7 di cui
normalmente cioè in assenza di
stimolazione non si sentivano
responsabili
e interessante notare come questo
avveniva solo se la stimolazione era
applicata prima dell'esecuzione
dell'azione a dimostrazione che il senso
di responsabilità
non emerge esclusivamente dopo la messa
in atto di uno specifico comportamento
ma inizia a formarsi già prima tramite
specifiche previsioni circa le
conseguenze che comporterà questo
comportamento ed interferire con
l'attività di specifiche regioni
cerebrali
provoca un'alterazione di queste
capacità predittive è una difficoltà nel
discriminare azione ed effetti prodotte
da noi rispetto ad azioni di effetti
prodotti da altre persone
possiamo quindi dire che il cervello ha
un ruolo fondamentale nella generazione
del senso di responsabilità
e le neuroscienze cognitive sono facendo
dei passi in avanti per una migliore
comprensione di questi aspetti che
rivestono un'importanza non solo etica e
sociale ma permettono anche una migliore
comprensione di una serie di patologie
neurologiche e psichiatriche
infatti i dati che vi ho appena
presentato sono il nostro punto di
partenza per formulare nuove ipotesi in
soccorso a una serie di condizioni
patologiche
caratterizzate da un'alterazione del
senso di responsabilità
pensate ad esempio ai pazienti affetti
da schizofrenia paranoide questi
pazienti sono affetti da un delirio di
controllo riportano cioè come le loro
azioni non sono controllate direttamente
dalla loro volontà ma sembrano piuttosto
essere dirette da o registe esterno bene
sulla base dei dati che vi ho presentato
potrebbe essere che questo registra
esterno non sia altro che una serie di
aree cerebrali che non funzionano come
dovrebbero funzionare
oltre allo studio di questi pazienti e
stiamo anche cercando di adattare i
nostri esperimenti a situazioni più
complesse soprattutto dal punto di vista
sociale e stato infatti dimostrato che
il nostro senso di responsabilità si
riduce significativamente
quando agiamo in un contesto coercitivo
per ricollegarmi all'inter nizio del mio
intervento infatti tendiamo a sentirci
meno responsabili quando agiamo per
obbedire agli ordini di qualcuno e
questo è particolarmente vero quando il
comportamento che mettiamo in atto per
obbedire a un comportamento che ha degli
effetti negativi ad esempio ci sentiremo
meno responsabili di somministrare una
piccola scossa elettrica ad un compagno
di esperimento quando è lo
sperimentatore che ci dice di farlo
piuttosto che farlo sulla base della
notte volontà nonostante la conseguenza
sia esattamente la stessa e abbia
effetti negativi in entrambe le
condizioni il fine ultimo della linea di
ricerca che vi ho presentato è infatti
quello di comprendere alcuni fenomeni
che caratterizzano la nostra società
come ad esempio la nostra tendenza a
sminuire la nostra responsabilità in
specifici contesti oppure a compiere
errori e di attribuzione del senso di
responsabilità quando giudichiamo eventi
che avvengono nel nostro ambiente
circostante e questo è particolarmente
vero quando ragioniamo su comportamenti
del passato i cui piani d'azione non
sono più presenti nella nostra mente per
comprendere al meglio tali fenomeni sarà
necessario capire come il cervello
genera il senso di responsabilità su
scale temporali più dilatate e per
comportamenti più complessi rispetto a
quelli che vi ho presentato oggi
scoperti questi misteri forse avremo un
mondo meno soggetto convinzioni
illusorie circa l'attribuzione di cause
ed effetti grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]